hi i'm maria today a friend will be
challenging me to take a popular food
and make it fancy today's friend it's
alex let's see what she wants me to make
fancy today hey really it's alex so
today i'm going to challenge you to make
one of my favorite sweet treats fancy
and that is skittles they're cute
they're colorful they are sweet and sour
if there's anyone who can do this it's
you i believe in you and i can't wait to
see what you make good luck
skittles i think i had one of their
varieties if alex eats a candy i think
she will be skittled it's very colorful
bold flavor they have grape lemon green
apple strawberry orange they say that
but they usually don't taste like that
let's try green
oh it's a little chewy i thought it was
hard candy it's not bad grape tastes a
little like cough syrup i like chewy
texture i like the hard shell i like the
flavor of green and yellow i think it's
going to be fun to play around with alex
is one of my best friends so i'm excited
to make it fancy
alright here's what i got raspberries
kumquats strawberries lemons eggs butter
heavy cream milk and buttermilk from the
pantry i got powdered sugar condensed
milk vanilla extract food coloring salt
baking soda flour sugar and vodka all
right let's get started
skittles it's upside down
making fancy skittles
so first i'm going to separate skittles
by color i feel like i've seen alex
doing this for hydra you could but i
don't remember which candy she used
right so i separated skittles by color
add a quarter cup of water quarter cup
of skittle i'm going to melt
it kind of gives me
that phobia i think anything around is
cute but if something all together makes
me uncomfortable yeah it's very
artificial smell the skittles completely
melted so i'm going to put in a bowl
clean the pan do the same thing with
green and pepper two and a half cup of
heavy cream and one can of condensed
milk start with lower speed because it
is very liquidy once it's a little bit
thicker go full blast until stiff peak
like this yeah this is easy ice cream
recipe divide it into three bowls where
do you think skittles were invented
skittles it's made by mars so i think
it's england
it seems like american candy somehow do
you have a guess as to when they were
invented
1973 1974.
i always
miss like one year
add two tablespoons each melted skittles
and skittle is
so bright if you mix together with like
white cream the color kind of
disappeared so i'm gonna use a little
bit of food color same thing with green
and purple i think alex would like it
because she likes light color and she
likes skittles and she likes ice cream
put this ice cream into cake pan but i
line cake pan with plastic wrap so when
you take it out it's easier you also
want to use a little bit oil underneath
it i tend to like a little bit muted
color than
loud color easy on the eyes freeze this
at least six hours preferably overnight
we have a towel freezer i'm going to put
in a tub freezer so i can shortcut the
time while it's freezing i'm going to
use mosquitoes with alcohol i have vodka
use one cup one cup is a lot of vocab
ah a half cup of pizza i'm using yellow
lemon flavor for this bring it to simmer
keto infused vodka i like using brandy
or rum for
pastry but this is some special thing
for alex once skittles are starting to
break down cover
remove from the heat let it dissolve
completely let it sit until it comes
down to room temperature it takes about
30 minutes i have one stick butter room
temperature one and a half cup of sugar
cream this together
adding room temperature egg one by one
because butter is room temperature so if
you put cold egg it will separate
and make sure everything is incorporated
before adding another egg
okay everything is incorporated so two
and a half cup of flour half teaspoon of
salt one teaspoon of baking soda just
mix well lemon and i'm going to zest use
whole lemon half cup of buttermilk
lemon juice in here i'm squeezing over
my hands so i can catch seeds did you
notice if there were more yellow
skittles
apparently
oh i always notice like the color
balance is very inconsistent i have half
cup of skittles vodka and mixed with
buttermilk and lemon juice next i'm
gonna add wet and dry ingredients
alternate starting with dry so the
reason why we alternate if you put dry
ingredients and wet ingredients all
together you tend to over mix it and i'm
adding one teaspoon of vanilla
i have two 8-inch cake mold lined with
parchment paper and greased divide cake
batter into two pans i just wanted to
make it wow bake these are 350 for 25
minutes to 30 minutes and do the
toothpick test and when toothpick comes
out clean it's ready just a reminder if
you want to check out our apron go to
shopmakingfancy.com okay so i'm going to
make butter cream frosting i have six
sticks of unsalted room temperature
butter a lot of butter and powdered
sugar that's why you don't eat birthday
cake every day so
i'm going to use 48 ounce powdered sugar
and you want to add powdered sugar
little by little
scraping
sides and
blade once in a while
i think skittles is something you would
eat without thinking anything like go to
movie theater watching and eat like
popcorn all right so i used up all the
sugar
the bottom is a little bit crumbly so
i'm going to add a little bit of milk to
make it smoother but make sure milk is
room temperature because butter is room
temperature if you use cold milk it will
cuddle and i'm adding three teaspoon of
vanilla extract for flavor
it looks nice and smooth so time to move
on we use all five colors and this is
the last one a quarter cup of red
skittles and you want to process until
it become very fine almost like a sand
you use the little mesh sieve just want
to use the fine powder look like crystal
add one tablespoon skittle powder i
think it's a little bit muted red so i'm
going to use food color to help the
color pop ray do you remember the first
time you met alex yes i started working
for tasty three months earlier
than alex and alex joined as an intern
she was very
outgoing and
it's kind of like opposite personality
to me so i was a little bit
scared of her
but we you know get to know each other
well and now you know we are
very close friend so don't judge people
from their first impression
it's what i learned
all right i think this is good and i'm
gonna paint other
buttercream one with yellow okay yeah
it's done
last one is orange
i think i like this color better because
it's a little bit muted with
white buttercream so it looks good so i
divided buttercream into three bowls and
i kept a little bit for crumb coat i
have baked and cooled the cake and crumb
coat vanilla butter cream frosting put
the slater knife in a half way cutting
it until
it's two even layers we are making four
layers total and this is the
ice cream we made earlier and the second
layer with orange
third layer easy to
handle it's super frozen
last one
so this is a little bit uneven but i can
use buttercream to make it even so i'm
going to stir crumb coat so i can
frost cake batter you walk fast because
on this is ice cream cake so you don't
want it to melt crumb coat it's like a
primer when you're painting wall
so it doesn't need to be perfect and i'm
going to freeze this for an hour one
hour later so we have tinted buttercream
and i'm going to decorate cake start
with yellow i'm gonna just
pipe kind of going for two like thick
ring around the cake and orange
and pink
put
leftover frosting
and use ball scraper and scrape
i have hot water in a bowl make it warm
so it's butter so it's kind of melts
with the hot temperature
all right size looks good spread
the gap when you decorate cake i like to
use little spatula so you can control
more so tops looking good sides are
looking great but we still have more
step left because it's alex i put in a
nice cake stand but i think the bottom
is a little bit uneven so i'm going to
use leftover buttercream and pipe and
hide some imperfection
and i have some fruit samplers i'm going
to decorate so decoration is freestyle
you can use any fruits you have i have
strawberries raspberries and kumquat so
the decoration is mimicking sketchup's
flavor
and we are done
[Music]
rainbow skittles shabbat cake very fancy
but we have to see what alex thinks
let's call her up
[Music]
alex
hi
welcome back to make it fancy i
sent you a mini version you sent me what
mini virgins i can't hear you i think
i'm gonna call you back oh okay great so
what happened we are waiting alex is
calling us back i think just like her
wifi is not
walking well hello oh my god
[Music]
it looks so good yeah
because of buzzfeed role on the stage we
have to keep the distance apart it's
[Music]
what do you think it's beautiful yeah it
looks like a sunset almost look like you
it's like a colorful
i was thinking i think it's been a
couple years and we gotta update your
dance okay so can you choliograph make
it fit
make it fancy
and make it fancy i can't do that
wait can you tell oh that was great
all right what do you got for me you
don't shower cake you have a way over
here
you know i want to go in the middle
wait no i got the whole thing
i'm not gonna cut it wow this is a dream
come true alex always eat her cake from
the middle the middle is better are you
upset that i'm doing this no wow is it
like ice cream
people are going to come after me for
doing this to your cake but like oh well
she told me i could
oh it's so good congratulations for
making me a good face thank you i asked
for skittles she saw the riddle the cake
wasn't little i ate the middle surprise
ri a she made it fancy
you are so talented
all right so we have one last thing to
do i know what it is it's our tradition
make it fuzzy
[Music]
you